there's nothing else to do here that's
another way to look at it you can try
endless programs the Antichrist is the
running of endless programs that are not
Christ the Antichrist is the running of
infinite endless programs that are not
Christ and so you'll notice that any
program that's not Christ any script
that's running that the body runs that
is not Christ is inherent
unfulfilling it is
unfulfilling and you know it you know it
is unfulfilling you know it's
unfulfilling and yet you keep
masturbating on unfulfilling programs
pretending like Christ is not your
answer to fulfillment you know Christ is
your answer to fulfillment you know you
need to crucify all of your
scripts in order to feel the Fulfillment
of taking on the collective sins and
healing the totality to abundance and
prosperity you know that that's the only
pathway and you pretend like it's not
the only pathway and you spin around in
all kinds of cesspools of circles of
programs and scripts and nonsense and
masturbations and then you hear a
catalyst like this and then finally it's
ah that's the reflection that I
wanted all these scripts I hate
these Scripts
actually Christ is the answer it is the
portal to God